[Music]
people asking us to have my day job
isn't what you do tedious as a
stop-motion animator you very conscious
of time and of incrementally moving a
three-dimensional object
bit by bit by bit mad God is a
stop-motion film that I've been kind of
making for like the last 30 years
there's nothing stopping me from
continuing doing it yeah forever when I
was five years old in 1955 I saw King
Kong mentality as a stupid kid I was
just involved by Hollywood monsters and
that was really the thing that kind of
kindled my appetite subsequently over
the years I have worn many hats in the
motion picture accurate I've been
involved with Star Wars the Robocop
series Jurassic Park Starship Troopers
on and on one of the things that gives
me a lot of pleasure is is to make
something but the day job has certain
requirements to it over the years those
requirements have become a lot more
limiting the Mad Dog project allowed me
to just make this more pure thing that
was kind of a form of therapy for me as
an antidote to my day job
it's a combination of live-action and
stop-motion miniatures sets in layers
like the collage for lack of a better
term it's a passion project and things
keep getting deeper and darker and honor
there are imaginary cities that are
built out of iron ingots there is like
strange jungles that you go to there's
this huge de stopping post-industrial
nightmare city and it just goes on and
on and on exactly anything that I can
think of inherent in it there's a level
of surprise that I think you know for me
is very childlike kind of thing I should
here at my studio in Berkeley it's
stocked with all kinds of stuff for all
kinds of different electronic projects
woodworking projects lights cameras so
it's a huge toy box all of the
characters in that God are built by me
the process begins with the articulated
skeleton and that's made by voluntati
door hinge joints that allow you to move
the characters incrementally one frame
at a time and then I just wrapped
lengths of polyurethane foam and build
up the general mass from there I will
take latex skin adhere them with rubber
cement paint the thing and it's ready to
shoot when you're actually shooting the
stop-motion scene you project into the
character and sometimes it can get very
complicated
you are always gauging acceleration and
deceleration weight and mass and then
that kind of lead to but you know what
what would make it better
for me this whole process is more of a
confession I really have no say over
it's just something that I I have to do
now I've been doing it so long it's it I
breed I live and breathe in this world
it's all I think about
you